[Music]
curtis is with us curtis is in lexington
kentucky hi curtis welcome to the ramsay
show
thank you dave
what's up
well i got a question i
like you tell from many other people i
think i know what you're going to say
but i wanted to ask anyway okay i've got
20 000 worth of credit card debt
and it's charging me around 24 interest
and so i was wondering if i was thinking
about refinancing my house because i can
save two percent on my mortgage and
doing a cash out to pay off the credit
cards
or do a heloc which would be around
seven or eight percent
and pay off the credit cards and pay off
the
heloc faster than i'm going to do paying
minimum payments on the credit card
what's your household income
about 45 to 50.
you have any money
no sir okay i got about 500
okay how old are you
65 okay
all right
well um
the problem is is that the credit card
debt is the symptom
of other things going on
and if you paid it off really really
fast the interest doesn't matter much
and it's going to be tough to pay it off
really really fast you're working 40
hours
do you work 40 hours a week
yes sir okay what do you do
i'm in transportation
okay all right are you married
yes sir and does she work
no sure how come
she's on disability oh okay so your
household income with you in
transportation and her disability
payments is a total of forty five
thousand dollars
yes sir okay all right cool
well
obviously the credit card debt is due to
overspending can we agree on that
agree okay credit cards have been cut up
that's good good first step well done
sir
all right and so then the trick is to
get rid of them as fast as possible you
really can't borrow your way out of debt
you're just moving it around and so
you're right i'm going to tell you not
to move it over onto your mortgage
but that's going to entail
that you guys really cut your budget to
the bone and do anything you can to
create some extra income
uh and and let's get those credit cards
paid off very very quickly see the
interest rate isn't the problem it's the
debt we've got to get rid of the debt
that's what's killing you and then the
interest is attached to that if you want
to refinance your mortgage in the
meantime
and lower your interest rate two percent
if you're going to keep the house that's
a wise thing to do but no i would not
recommend a cash out because i don't
want your move credit card debt where
you bought a stake you couldn't afford
and
uh you now you financed it 30 years over
on the house
and that that's what ends up that's what
credit card debt is i mean it was crappy
bought at target now it's financed 30
years over at the house or it's
something or you know repair on the car
and now it's financed 30 years over on
the house and so i just it just it just
sticks in my throat and i just can't i
can't tell you to do that i don't think
it's wise long term short term it feels
pretty good and you're right it does get
rid of a high interest rate but i i
really really really want you to do
something to get your income up your out
go down and slam that credit card debt
and say hey
sometime in the next uh 18 to 24 months
it's going to be gone that means 10 000
bucks a year extra coming from somewhere
part-time job something
and uh attacking that and and forcing it
and getting rid of it but i'm proud of
you for cutting up those cars that's a
big first step
and um
uh since i'm in the old dog club too i
can say this it's tough for us old dogs
to learn new tricks i'm proud of you for
doing that and can i tell you um i just
for some encouragement here i've watched
my my dad's 70 and watched him
transition a couple of different
positions over the last few years and
he's found something that he just
absolutely loves about two years ago
and so still within the same basic
um realm of his expertise but i want to
encourage curtis it may feel like i'm 65
no one's going to hire me i can't do
anything else so i'm just stuck doing
this thing that may or may not be true
depending on where you live and what you
want to do and what you're willing to
invest to learn something new and i've
watched my old man do it it's pretty
neat curtis i think you can do it like
dave said
there may be some late nights at driving
and driving on top of driving but
just get this stuff out of your life and
you're going to stand six inches taller
when this thing's over yeah it changes
everything for you